all right so we looked at four fallacies
last time for mathematical results
they're paradoxical because they seem to
hold together logically but then when
you get to the end you get something
which is completely bogus it doesn't
make any sense at all okay so how does
this make sense
what's the hole in the logic which is
why you get to a false result and you
find one okay now you can see some our
lines are really obvious you can tell
that there's no problems there okay so
for example I'm going from this line to
this line clearly there's no issues you
can multiply both sides by a their
problems okay in much the same way on
line seven to eight for instance there's
no issues because you can divide both
sides by a B that's not going to cause
you any problems okay so clearly it's
somewhere here in the middle as it turns
out it is exactly the middle okay so
where is the problem line here it is
right here okay
so the question then becomes what is
this line problem or why is the
transition between those two lines a
problem and the reason why is you've got
to think carefully about what's
happening what has changed from line 4
line 5 is that line dividing what am i
dividing by right after I factorize to
give me this line to this line I have to
divide by this common factor a where it
is B right
that's how I'll just be here and just a
plus B over here okay but that's sneaky
right what's the reason why you can't
divide by anybody speed what is a minus
B you think I don't know it because a be
a random numbers they're not written
numbers they're equal numbers all right
so if you look at this line which is our
starting point our foundation write a
minus B is equal to 0 and we already
looked at earlier this year the fact
that division by 0 causes logically
inconsistent results okay so sneaky
division by 0 into the logic but doing
it in a sort of subtle way that's not so
obvious that's the way a lot of these
fallacy proofs
work
okay so here's the problem replied
forward to my five division by zero is
why it doesn't work okay